ce train qui roule donc à 300 kilomètres
à l'heure et plus rapide que le tgv
sud-est que vous connaissez bien qui lui
se contente de 270 km à l'heure il
comporte également comme l'a dit william
de nombreuses améliorations pour le
confort des voyageurs
reportage philippe dumaine le dépôt de
châtillon à l'ouest de paris
ici on entretient on répare on améliore
les tgv atlantique et c'est ici que les
mécaniciens viennent prendre leur train
pour apprendre à le connaître et faire
des voyages décès et d'entraînement
moi j'ai commencé j'ai passé l'examen
vapeur en 1964 et j'ai commencé à rouler
comme nommé élèves mécaniciens en avril
1965 et quel effet ça vous fait de
conduire des trains aussi sophistiquée
moi j'ai toujours roulé à 160 kilomètres
à l'heure et là je roule à 300 km heure
il faut être beaucoup plus vigilant dans
l'observation de la voie monsieur tu
oublies nez comme tous les autres
conducteurs de tgv à ondes et des
sélectionnés avec beaucoup de rigueur
par la sncf si les principaux
instruments n'ont pas été beaucoup
modifié l'informatique en revanche a
fait une entrée en force dans les
chemins de fer dans chaque rame ces
ordinateurs servent à aider le
mécanicien pour la conduite du train
mais aussi ils permettent d'effectuer
tous les contrôles de sécurité de
mémoriser les défauts afin de rendre les
réparations le plus simple possible et
l'entretien très facile dans sa cabine
le mécanicien a donc un assistant
électronique largement justifiée par le
fait que rouler à 300 kilomètres à
l'heure n'est pas du tout évident si on
veut garder un maximum de sécurité
les interventions en cas d'anomalie
doivent être plus rapide parce que la
distance parcourue dans l'unique corner
l'unité de temps bien sûr croît
constamment et tout un anomalie relevée
doit être bien sûr de nécessite une
réaction immédiate des conducteurs donc
d'autant plus rapide qu'on roule vite
inutile de préciser que les systèmes de
freinage sont très performants à 300
kilomètres à l'heure vous faites 83
mètre par seconde en freinage d'urgence
à cette allure le tgv à peut s'arrêter
en 2008 100 m seulement et le confort
impressionnant espace est une nouvelle
suspension pneumatique qui élimine
presque toutes les vibrations
l'aménagement intérieur de ce train un
peu révolutionnaire a été aussi très
bien étudié les premières classes
surtout n'ont plus rien à envier au
pullman de luxe en tout cas on n'a
jamais l'impression de rouler vite sauf
peut être lorsque l'on double les
voitures sur l'autoroute a10 ou que l'on
traverse les tunnels et que fait cette
dame elle téléphone une innovation que
beaucoup de voyageurs attendaient certes
tout ne marche pas encore parfaitement
les ordinateurs en font parfois leur
tête mais la période d'essai jusqu'en
septembre permettra sûrement de corriger
toutes les anomalies